Polen übt den Griff zur Waffe
schließlich herrscht im Nachbarland
Krieg für den Ernstfall soll jeder
gerüstet sein survival Training und
Nahkampftechniken jeder Pole kann an
solchen Militärübungen teilnehmen Soldat
sein für einen
Tag wir sind beim Training in Serge in
der Nähe von Warschau
dabei
selen Vers
zuen warum machen Sie hier
mit ich glaube an den Grundsatz man für
alle Fälle über bestimmte Fähigkeiten
und kennniss verfügen
sollte sie nicht anwenden dass wir sie
einfach nie brauchen das ist wie bei der
Ersten Hilfe jeder sollte es wissen aber
hoffentlich nicht
brauchen das eigene Sicherheitsgefühl
Stärken ein wichtiges Thema im Wahlkampf
die peace Regierung verkauft sich als
Garant für Sicherheit auffallend auch
viele Minderjährige sind bei der
Militärübung dabei die Armee sucht
Nachwuchs
wir machen uns auf nach chartajev einem
kleinen Ort nur 30 km entfernt von der
Grenze zu
barus dort herrscht Feststimmung das
Familienministerium hat den ganzen
Sommer über sogenannte pickncks
organisiert mit bunten Luftballons wird
dabei vor allem die Erhöhung des
Kindergelds von 500 auf 800 swti
gefeiert mit steuergern wwerb so der
Vorwurf der Opposition an die regierende
rechtskonservative peaceptei die hier
reichlich Geschenke
verteilt die Opposition sagt es ist
Werbung für die
peaceosition erhebt allerlei Vorwürfe
die sich nicht als W erweisen
grundsätzlich lässt sich sagen dass wir
in allen Bereichen auf ähnliche Kritik
gestoßen sind dass sich hier vorwck oder
unerfülltes versprechen
handelt
im Grunde hat die Opposition einfach
keine Argumente und erfet einige
Sachen Geld für Familien und für Militär
darauf setzt die peace im Wahlkampf das
ist auch in chartajev nicht zu übersehen
hüpburg Zuckerwatte und Infostand stehen
hier Seite an Seite mit
Militärgerät ein echter Publikumsmagnet
auch für die beiden Söhne von Emilia der
neunjährige Adam darf man die Waffe in
die Hand nehmen ganz entspannt halten l
deinen Finger nicht am
Abzug die Waffe ist offensichtlich nicht
geladen nein nein Adams Mutter sieht die
erhöhte Militärpräsenz in der Region mit
gemischten
Gefühlen es FÄ mir schwer zu sagen ob
ich damit glücklich bin oder nicht
einerseits können wir uns einigermaßen
beschützt fühlen andererseits gibt es
eine Bedrohung wenn etwas auftaucht
denken wir auch dass es gegen uns
gerichtet sein
könnte nächste Station unser
Danzig wie fast alle Großstädte eine
Hochburg der Opposition die weltoffene
Ostseemetropole ist Heimat von Donald
Tusk Spitzenkandidat der oppositionellen
Bürgerplattform ich besuche einen
wahlkampfaftritt im europäischen
solidaritätszentrum der ehemalige
Präsident des Europäischen Rates steht
gerade besonders in der Schusslinie von
Schmutzkampagnen der Regierungspartei
peace Tusk wird als Kandidat
Deutschlands
beschimpft hier aber hat er
Heimspiel ich muss zugeben dass dieses
Treffen für mich eine einzigartige
Herausforderung
ist wenn meine Stimme ein wenig zittert
liegt das an echten
Gefühlen wir werden gewinnen skieren
seinehänger klingt es müsste man sich
selbst Mut
machen ja vielen Dank für diese Worte
ich bin zu Hause
tatsächlich dieser Ort dieser Tag ist
für uns alle voller
Erinnerungen wir sind aber voll auf die
Zukunft
fusst und die
zukunftut
noch einmal gewinnen so lautet das KEDO
hier es se eine Richtungswahl um ein
abtriften in die Autokratie zu
verhindern Tusk verspricht die
angeschlagene Beziehung Polens zur EU
wieder in Ordnung zu bringen Bedenken
beim Thema Rechtsstaatlichkeit aus dem
Weg zu
räumen das erzählt mir auch die Danziger
Abgeordnete anjeska pomaska die wir in
der Menschenmenge
Treffen mit ihr verabreden wir uns für
den nächsten Tag am von Danzig abseits
vom
wahlkampftrubel was wird denn die Wahl
entscheiden im Wahlkampf geht es immer
um Emotionen und derzeit gibt es unter
uns Polen wirklich viele wenn wir uns
einmal die Lebenshaltungskosten ansehen
hohe Preise Inflation ganz allgemein die
wirtschaftliche
Lage Donald Tusk wird von der
Regierungspartei als Kandidat
Deutschlands bezeichnet
welchen Einfluss hat
das weil sie schwach sind für mich ist
das ein Zeichen der Schwäche dass sie
Angst vor Donald Tusk haben es ist
jemand der sehr aktiv ist und sehr gut
wenn man sich seine öffentlichen
Auftritte und Veranstaltungen ansieht
also hat Herr Kinski beschlossen dass er
Herrn Tusk als jemanden darstellen muss
der kein Pole ist und der nicht für die
herzensthemen des polnischen Volkes
kämpft
die Partei von Donald Tusk hat noch ein
Problem der Spitzenkandidat ist zwar
allgemein beliebt doch als junger
Hoffnungsträger gilt er mit seinen 66
Jahren nicht
mehr ein Problem dass die ultraarechte
Partei konfederatiia nicht hat wir sind
in Torun auch hier eine
Wahlkampfveranstaltung das Publikum
vorwiegend jung die Spitzenkandidaten
Männer Typ must
schwiegersoh ihnen treffen wir neben der
Bühne Christop borsag 41 Jahre alt
Abgeordneter im same dem polnischen
Parlament was kann die konfedera bieten
was andere nicht
können wir sind die einzige Partei die
wirklich darauf Wert legt dass wir die
Rechte und Interessen von einfachen
Menschen repräsentieren von normalen
Menschen nicht die Agenda von der
Europäischen Union oder anderen globalen
Playern wir wollen ökonomische
Freiheiten stehen für Bürgerrechte und
nationale
Interessen mit solch populistischen
Parolen erreichen Sie in Umfragen
teilweise bis zu 15% damit könnten sie
nach der Wahl mit darüber entscheiden
wer die Regierung führt Polen könnte
noch weiter nach rechts rücken im
Wahlkampf aber bestreitet bossak eine
mögliche Koalition mit der peace das
würde nicht zur antiestablishment
Erzählung
passen
ieren weil die PE nichts tun will was im
Interesse des polnischen Volkes ist und
sie wollen auch nichts tun das zu
unserer Agenda passt wir werden nicht
aufgeben unsere Wähler und das polnische
Volk zu
vertreten vor allem die Geldpolitik der
Regierung kritisiert die konfederatiia
mit viel Tamtam einen symbolischen
Geldregen lassen sie auf iher Anhänger
niedergehen in Anspielung auf die hohe
Inflation im
landelier
m rter gleichzetig verspricht man allen
Polen ein Häuschen mit Grill Auto und
Urlaub auch mit Hilfe der EU nur mehr
mitreden soll Europa
[Musik]
nicht wir glauben dass europäische
Zusammenarbeit und freier Handel in der
EU allen gut tut und wir sollten das auf
dem aktuellen Level auch beibehalten
aber nicht weiter
ausbauen das Geld von der EU wollen sie
aber natürlich
natürlich fedia vereinen sich viele
Rechte Strömungen wirtschaftsnahe
eu-skeptiker Monarchisten eine wilde
Mischung mit Erfolg auch dank
tiktok konfederchef slavomir menen hat
sich dort eine riesige followerschaft
aufgebaut um die 780 000 User Millionen
von likes er punktet mit einfachen
Botschaften macht auf kuriose Gesetze
aufmerksam gibt sich bürgernah und
harmlos auch abseits von tiktok und
wahlkampfbühne plegt men Image vom
Politiker zum Anfassen im PAP seiner
eigenen Brauerei kann man ihn nach dem
wallkampfauftritt in Torun ganz locker
auf ein
biertreffen schrecklich findet das Barte
kjolbowitsch ich treffe den Künstler in
seinem Atelier in Warschau er ist in den
letzten Jahren zu einer lauten Liberalen
Stimme geworden zur konfederatiia hat er
eine eindeutige
Meinung für mich dies eine der
gefährlichsten Parteien und eine der
größten Bedrohungen für die polnische
Demokratie sie wünschen sich dass sie 0%
bekommen ich träume davon dass sie 0%
haben würden und das ist der Versuch
einer solchen Prognose für Bartek sind
die Politiker der ultrarechten Partei
Faschisten ihre sogenannten Argumente
sind denen Hitlers sehr ähnlich sie
versprechen ein Wirtschaftswunder und
null steuern das ist die ganze Utopie
und so ein Unsinn
der Künstler hat am eigenen Leib erlebt
wie schon jetzt Kritiker der
Regierungspolitik Repressalien erfahren
bis vor kurzem leitete er noch Kurse für
Kunststudenten an der Warschauer Uni
seine laute Kritik und Protestaktionen
auch gegen die regierungsparteiace
kosteten ihn den Job um die Zukunft
Polens machte sich große
Sorgen unser größtes Problem ist dass
wir miteinander streiten dass die
Gesellschaft mit sich selbst uneins ist
dass wir eine sehr polarisierte
Gesellschaft haben die nicht miteinander
klarkmt was unsere Regierung tut was
peace tut ist der Versuch die
Gesellschaft zu spalten und sich auf
diese Emotionen zu verlassen Bartek
provoziert mit seiner Kunst auch Kritik
an der in Polen so wichtigen
katholischen Kirche findet seinen Platz
er zeigt uns seine Ausstellung in der
Innenstadt 33 Bilder des polnischen
Papstes Johannes Paul der in Polen immer
noch als ikonische Figur verehrt
wird Portraits sind hell übertüncht
erfordert weniger politischen Einfluss
der katholischen Kirche im
Land die Kirche ist wie eine politische
Partei sie unterstützt die
Regierungspartei peace die Machthaber
Priester von den Kanzeln sagen wen man
wählen soll und verurteilen den Westen
als faulen Westen sie verwenden genau
die gleichen Argumente wie Putin es ist
schrecklich für Barte und seine Frau
geht es bei der Wahl im um die Zukunft
des Landes und ihre eigene sollte es zu
einer Koalition von Peace und konfedera
kommen wollen sie mit ihrem kleinen Sohn
das Land
verlassen bei unserer Reise wurde
deutlich wie zerrissen Polen ist
zwischen Stadt und Land konservativer
und liberalerer Politik die diesjährige
parlamentsmal wird entscheidend führt
der Weg zu mehr Nationalismus oder
wieder größerer Nähe zu europ
[Musik]
pa